hey guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're going to talk about the macro
confusion on a ketogenic and intermittent
fasting plan okay
macros are the percentages of
carbohydrates proteins and fats on a
certain plan okay that's what that means
now some of you don't have a confusion
and others do have a confusion and if
you really understood this before you're
really gonna be confused after I'm done
with this so the first thing I'm gonna
say is I'm really sorry you're gonna
kill me after doing this video because
it'll put you in a little bit of a
confusion but at the end I'll clear it
out okay so watch this whole video all
right and I'm sorry that I had to do
this but I just need to bring it up I
mean this is why I haven't done this
video before because I didn't want to
add another layer until maybe people got
started and starting becoming successful
because if you watch this video as
someone that's just starting you're
probably gonna give up because it is a
little confusing but let me just kind of
let the cat out of the bag and explain
why it's confusing okay
now typically if you look up keto you're
gonna see that the percentages are 5%
carbs 20% protein and 75% fat okay but
now we're gonna add in another variable
we're gonna add in in a minute fasting
which confuses everything okay we're
gonna go to two meals a day and then for
some people down to one meal a day okay
because those percentages then change
okay
now just to keep this simple I'm gonna
be using throughout this video 1,800
calories for three meals a day on
average it could be more it could be
less
1,500 calories total for two meals a day
okay and 1200 calories for one meal a
day and this is just average of what I
found people do alright it could be
different for you but the point is that
these calories reduction don't go down
in a certain rate they have their own
rate of change in other words if you're
starting out with three meals 1,800
calories
and then down to one male we're gonna
reduce the amount of total calories at a
certain rate that has a certain variable
on itself that's not really dependent on
three males two males and one middle so
it has no mathematical similarity so
that's number one confusion okay because
what happens as you reduce the frequency
of eating okay you start retaining more
nutrients so if you're going to consume
1800 calories for three meals and keep
the calories the same and 1800 calories
for one male it's gonna be really hard
to consume that much fruit okay so we
have to reduce that and that throws up
the percentages right there all right so
that's confusion number one or actually
could be two and then we have another
variable I wanted to add in their actual
non starchy vegetables that are not
included in these carbs right here these
carbs are like berries avocado nuts
tomatoes carrot beet okay these
carbohydrates are non starchy like leafy
greens broccoli kale these other
vegetables and this comes out to like
five percent okay so what I want to do
is I want to show you in three meals
ideally you should have ten cups divided
by three so what does that come out to
three and a half cups of salad per meal
okay just envision that so we want at
the end of the day ten cups of vegetable
or salad for a three mil when you go to
to meal because your body is more
efficient you're gonna go eight cups of
vegetable or salad so that would be like
four and four four cups four cups with
each meal that's not hard to do right
and then when you get down to one meal
the salad or vegetable would be seven
cups of vegetable or salad and again
that's a nice sized salad and again this
is just average if I'm going to do one
meal today I'll do ten cups of salad but
I'm just giving you just kind of what
I'm gonna be building into this
to make it doable for the average person
because as you reduce your frequency of
eating you actually do not need the same
amount of nutrients because you go
through different metabolic adaptations
so your body actually holds more
nutrients and if you can keep it to 20
grams or less that would be even better
okay but for going from three meals to
two meals to one meal you can keep this
the same okay you can keep this the same
so in other words keep in 20 grams 20
grams 20 grams that's going to alter the
percentage of total calories so that's
another confusion people have but now
the thing to focus on is just keep your
carbs below 30 grams okay 20 would be
ideal lat 30 on average whether it's
three meals two meals or one meal just
for the day okay you can divide it up
any way you want alright now the next
confusion I'm sorry to do this to you
we're gonna talk about proteins the
percentage of total calories will stay
the same 20 percent 20 percent and 20
percent over here that carbohydrates
that's going to change the percentage of
total calories of carbs are going to
change but protein is going to stay the
same all right but what's gonna change
is the grams of protein in the or the
ounces okay so on average on a three
meal a day program you'll do four ounces
like three to six but let's just talk
about let's just use four as an example
so four ounces of protein per meal on a
two meal per day in a minute fasting
five ounces per meal okay that's 75
grams if you're doing a one meal a day
eight ounces of protein for that meal
okay again that's an average you could
have more a little less so that's the
confusion number that six yeah okay
don't worry I have more confusion for
you so we have that variable right here
and then we have the fat variable okay
so this is the wild wild card because
what happens in the beginning when
you're doing this program
you're gonna need more fat as you start
doing it you'll need a little less fat
because your body is eating your own fat
so you want to basically go based on
your hunger and not doing too much so
you're not too stuffed
okay but an average for a three meal
program you would do a hundred and forty
grams per day two meal would be 113
grams and for a one meal you do 86 grams
of fat okay so that's the confusion and
now here's the solution okay I am
building a calculator for you so you can
plug in what you ate and it'll tell you
if it's correct or what to focus on okay
so you're welcome I'm gonna really work
on trying to get that Dennis soon as
possible number two the meal plans on my
site under recipe I already have all
this stuff built into it so all you have
to do is go there and follow it and you
can visualize the foods that you should
use alright so I hope that helped you
maybe not now you're totally pissed off
at me but I wanted to kind of bring this
up let the cat out of the bag and we do
have a solution but it's a little
complex let's focus on that and not
these complexes but for those people
that want to know there you have it
alright thanks for watching hey before
you go definitely sign up for my free
keto course I put a link down below it's
on messenger in Facebook but it will
give you all the basics it's very quick
it's like three or four videos and it's
free check it out